notre série de portraits à présent avoir
20 ans dans les années 2020 rencontre ce
midi avec arrêt dabadie dit il vit dans
le quartier de la fontaine d'ouche à
dijon il est comédien et à seulement 21
ans il rêve déjà d'hollywood bamba guèye
et gabrielle talon
c'est dieu c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir un temps en 2009 c'est
dur
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle rien dabadie dit
j'ai 21 ans et j'habite au quartier de
la fontaine d'ouche depuis 20 ans
aujourd'hui je suis comédien
j'en ai toujours le plus voilà donc ici
on est à la place de la fontaine d'ouche
c'est le coeur du quartier le milieu là
où il ya la mairie là où il ya le
théâtre là où il ya la bibliothèque la
crèche le centre commercial donc ça
permet au quartier de la fontaine
d'ouche de s'exporter d'attirer plein de
gens de l'extérieur en un mot si je
devais décrire le quartier de la
fontaine d'ouche dirait
diversité c'est vraiment ce mot que je
pense ma m'a permis aussi dans ma vie
actuelle de faire les rencontres que
j'ai fait devenu l'expérience que j'ai
vécue reda madi dit
je vais toujours pas renoncé pourquoi je
ferais ça
après 21 ans passés dans ton quartier
fontaine d'ouche le pire souvenir cessé
de se souvenir de personnes qu'on aimait
et qu'au final
finisse pas comme on le souhaite voir
que la personne se détruit parfois ça
peut ça peut être tout nouveau
c'est là on se réunissait tous et c'est
vrai ça marque vraiment l'époque de
l'insouciance est exposée la dans le
rond central et parlé c'était des heures
et des heures de ti match après des fois
d'autres petits trucs mais
c'était de la chamaillerie couverture on
était si tu es enfant tu as toujours
dans le bon esprit que se passe-t-il
quartier de la fontaine-d'ouche à dijon
la question se pose alors que des scènes
de violence se répète depuis plusieurs
semaines et qu'une nouvelle fusillade a
éclaté hier en plein jour
c'est à dire que ça se passe dans mon
quartier et forcément ça m'attriste
parce que je préférais que ça ne se
passe pas tout simplement reda c'est une
relation de très longue date on se
connaît depuis depuis depuis le début un
depuis la naissance nos mamans étaient
déjà très amis et
et à notre naissance soit on est on est
sorti de l'hôpital ensemble et c'est de
là que tout a commencé on a on a vécu à
fontaine d'ouche toutes nos années
d'enfance et c'est là bas qu'on a on a
eu nos meilleurs souvenirs leurs galères
est-ce que c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans dans
les années 2020
je dirais que non parce que tout
simplement c'est pas plus dur que
d'avoir dix ans n'est pas plus dur
d'avoir 30 ans chaque génération chaque
âge à son autre problème à son autre
succès
je m'appelle mon coeur au fond du
tableau tu dois être acteurs s'étaient
d'abord ma vocation et c'était pour moi
le seul moyen de conjurer un travail et
l'épanouissement personnel tout ça pour
faire le clown devant une caméra sait
tous que c'est pour te faire le clown
font-elles de ce sera toujours une
partie de ma vie sera toujours chez moi
je me sentirai toujours comme chez moi
après la vie à une nous mène elle-même
forcément ailleurs aujourd'hui le projet
que j'ai en restant ici ils sont pas
atteignables concrètement donc forcément
on va falloir s'en détacher dans le
temps je ne vois pas au niveau d une
grosse production américaine des stars
comme pour marseille tom hanks à mes
côtés